And a high percentage of uh,
like predominantly female professors as well.
And their whole thing is social justice and it's like there when you know,
their lists or objectives as far as education,
like social justice is number one.
It's number one.
It's like the thing that they emphasize the most.
Well what's it going to be?
Architecture.
Well,
education.
Sure.
I guess.
But I think universities are there to promulgate an ideology,
right.
But they literally framed it as social justice and that does,
that term today is so fraught with peril.
I'll,
yeah,
it's the enemy.
Yeah.
It's such a goofy term like social justice.
Like it's so it's such a blanket term and so all encompassing and it,
you know,
you,
you hear it and you start thinking about people banging on Tucker Carlson's door
and saying,
we know where you sleep.
That's what I hear.
I mean,
well yeah,
no,
and I hear is like,
I was just talking about just a couple of minutes ago.
It means 90% of people have agreed the 10% who don't agree need to be shut down
because we're talking about social justice.
The,
there's no such thing as individual justice because that's subordinate.
Well,
I don't even know.
I mean,
what percentage of people would agree with banging on a guy's house?
Like knocking on his door and saying,
we know you're asleep.
I mean,
that is you.
This is us form of mental terrorism.
Like threatening him.
You're scaring him.
I don't think most people are capable of empathy by which they mean they can't
put themselves in Tucker shoes.
So all they see is someone I hate had something bad happen to hit him good.
And they don't understand.
Like when these Republicans are saying that it's okay to torture terrorists,
right?
And the point I make is there's people right now,
uh,
Michael,
Ian Black or will tell you a tweet out every day the NRA is a terrorist
organization.
So what happens when the government defines you as a terrorist,
right?
You're going to,
and then you're gonna say,
well,
it never happened to me.
That's not how it works,
right?
That's the fear.
So you,
we,
if you're going to have principals,
you have to apply them to people that you hate.
And Tucker Carlson is hardly some Nazi,
right?
No,
it mean Tucker Carlson is if,
if you think that he has ideas that are questionable,
the solution is to present better ideas and to debate him and to go back and
forth to them.
But Tucker Cross is not leading some hate mob.
He's not the centerpiece in Charlottesville pride for the extermination of the
Jews.
Or He's not that radical.
No,
he's just a right wing guy.
Well,
what they,
what,
what critical theory allows them to do is to say,
well,
you can read between the lines and ascribing tent to the person,
right?
So if you read a book,
you can say,
well this is race because I can't see reason.
So they can easily say,
well,
when he says a,
B,
and c,
he means x,
Y,
and z.
So these are all dog whistles and you can impugn whatever motives do you want
onto a person.
And,
and,
and at that point you could do whatever you want.
And the thing is,
he's a dad.
So not only you have to be comfortable with,
with fucking,
with Tucker Carlson's house,
you gotta be careful with scaring as kids.
Yeah,
exactly.
And,
and I think the history of totalitarian show totalitarianism shows us they're
more than happy to sacrifice the kids to get their goal.
It just really disturbing to me because I think these idealistic kids who are
doing this,
they're mostly young people have a fundamental lack of understanding when it
comes to what violence is and what causes violence.
And this is intentional and how,
how close that scene was to violence.
Yes.
Cause you do that to the wrong guys door.
He's going to come out with a baseball bat or a gun and he's going to kill some
people or smash some people write it.
It absolutely can happen.
It's not likely to happen with a guy like Tucker Carlson.
But what if they decided to go after the wrong general?
I would if they decided to go after the,
I mean anything can happen in these situations.
And also those people were all going to get outed.
Once those people are outed,
the outrage that they're gonna experience is going to be an handleable.
Right.
It's going to be unmanageable.
The the amount of people that are furious at that group of 20 or what,
how many people was it?
I don't even know.
It was plenty.
I'm angry.
I mean I'm not going to do anything but I'm angry.
I think it was disgusting.
If,
if I'm angry,
how many really loosely held people,
people that are just like really barely keeping it together already,
but here's the scary,
it's not those 20 that are going to get the consequences.
It's going to be people who think like them,
who haven't done what they did and now it's going to be like,
oh,
you agree with this?
Then it's,
I'm going to do it to you.
I think it's going to be them too though.
It's going to be both.
Yeah.
I think those people don't understand like people are going to find their names.
They're going to find where they live and there's going to be people that have
nothing to do with this,
not Tucker Carlson,
and it's not them,
and these people are going to seek them out and they're going to,
it's going to get ugly.
You can't just bang on people's doors like that and scare them.
Right.
Because people get furious.
Especially when there's not enough.
There's not enough evidence.
This is not a bad guy.
Tucker Carlson is not some evil demon.
You know,
like if you,
if you looked at who he is and what he said,
if you pulled out the worst shit that he said and,
and taking it in comparison to the woman that we were talking about from MSNBC,
that's still in the air,
right?
Dwayne reed who lied about her blog being hacked and Twitter lied.
Yeah.
Just to try to cover up for the fact that she said some blatantly homophobic
things in the past and we called it and called in the FBI,
which is fucking insane.
That should be a federal crime.
You were moving resources from people that are already on very serious cases
that are already trying to solve real,
real crimes,
save people's lives,
save people's safety,
and you're deciding that your job at MSNBC is more important than that,
and she hasn't even fired.